Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
This is one of those simulation papers where
you can look at it for three seconds and immediately
know what it’s about.
Let’s try that!
Clearly, expansion and baking is happening.
And now, let’s look inside.
Mmmm!
Yup, this is done.
Clearly, this is a paper on simulating the
process of baking!
Loving the idea.
So how comprehensive is it?
Well, other than these phenomena, for a proper
baking procedure, the simulator also has to
be able to deal with melting, solidification,
dehydration, coloring and much, much more.
This requires developing a proper thermomechanical
model where these materials are modeled as
a collection of solids, water, and gas.
Let’s have a look at some more results.
And we have to stop right here, because I’d
like to tell you that the information density
on this deceivingly simple scene is just stunning.
In the x axis, from the left to the right
we have a decreasing temperature in the oven,
left being the hottest, and chocolate chip
cookies above are simulated with an earlier
work from 2014.
The ones in the bottom row are made with the
new technique.
You can see a different kind of shape change
as we increase the temperature, discoloration
if we crank the oven up even more, and…look
there!
Even the chocolate chips are melting.
Oh my goodness!
What a paper!
Talking about information density, you can
also see here how these simulated pieces of
dough of different viscosities react to different
amounts of stress.
Viscosity means the amount of resistance against
deformation, therefore, as we go up, you can
witness this kind of resistance increasing.
Here you can see a cross section of the bread
which shows the amount of heat everywhere.
This not only teaches us why crust forms on
the outside layer, but you can see how the
amount of heat diffuses slowly into the inside.
This is a maxed out paper.
By this, I mean the execution quality is through
the roof, and the paper is considered done
not when it looks alright, but when the idea
is being pushed to the limit and the work
is as good as it can be without trivial ways
to improve it.
And the results are absolute witchcraft.
Huge congratulations to the authors.
In fact, double congratulations because it
seems to me that this is only the second paper
of Mengyuan Ding, the lead author, and it
has been accepted to the SIGGRAPH ASIA conference,
which is one of the greatest achivements a
computer graphics researcher can dream of.
A paper of such quality for the second try.
Wow.
This episode has been supported by Weights
& Biases.
Weights & Biases provides tools to track your
experiments in your deep learning projects.
It can save you a ton of time and money in
these projects and is being used by OpenAI,
Toyota Research, Stanford and Berkeley.
They have excellent tutorial videos, in this
one, the CEO himself teaches you how to build
your own neural network, and more.
Make sure to visit them through wandb.com/papers
or just click the link in the video description
and you can get a free demo today.
Our thanks to Weights & Biases for helping
us make better videos for you.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!